all you can do is get really good at
what you do and if you get really good
at what you do and be kind cuz stand-up
is relentless it's ruthless oh great
special now you got to start all over
again
oh that's wrong on that right now we're
people you just can't it's gonna drop
Saturday and I know for a [ __ ] fact
I'm gonna go to tweet next week that's
like wins the next one my answer is
sucker
I write I have to write no matter what a
happy hour right do you read the
comments though cuz you're gonna get
people to like that look it's uh I
turned I turned I took Twitter off my
phone in October of 2018 why cuz I it
was ruining great experiences I would be
out at this [ __ ] therapy had a concert
like we wouldn't saw war on drugs me and
big J so our war on drugs at terminal 5
having this unbelievable job smoked a
joint [ __ ] love them they're a great
band I look at my phone and it's like
full Koontz god never made me laugh and
then I'm like who the [ __ ] are you [ __ ]
and I'm going to this guy's tweets well
this guy's tweets and it's a band that I
love is playing a Mikey [ __ ]
[ __ ] and I'm like oh never done
that one time oh it's not one that's a
you're good at hobby one see Joel Derby
yeah I I just roll missed it but I've
always got I know realizing I also know
from acting that so I learned this from
reviews so reading reviews if you do a
flag you've always told me not yeah if
you do a play you get yeah I would get
seven great reviews and then there'd be
the one comment and I was like and I
remember that this is exactly what my
acting teacher said he said that one
comment will [ __ ] haunt you don't
listen or read anything including and
especially good but now it's good will
define you yeah I don't want to [ __ ]
hear it I know what we're doing I do my
work do your work but here's one of the
reasons why I only now at like I'll post
and I delete the app Instagram I don't
have my phone smart I don't have
Instagram during the week then I go on
the road I post like pitch my food or
whatever my friends are the shows then
Sunday a young plane I delete the app
because here's the problem people go cuz
the negativity both the positive your
like off on the next
oh yeah I don't need to work that I'm
good too it's relaxed is you because I
get you know it's 90 maybe 10 90 people
are great in the 10 bath but either way
it's not gonna like the great never had
that like chappelle's the hardly they
like me they really like doesn't have
social media yeah all we did is we just
here we would just you go out here it's
just like Kali I don't know you don't
notice that 7 8 people that don't like
[ __ ] also you remember the bombs more
than you remember the kill always you
remember the bombs were your life of
human a Tony Oh Santa Antonio that
weekend I spent at [ __ ] the River
Center comedy club haunts me in a way
where I'm like I remember eating [ __ ]
every night yeah to finally on the
sunday show I snapped at the audience
and I was like you want to know how I
know you guys don't have good taste
because you vacation in San Antonio and
one guy just goes hey I got you great
comeback that's so funny but even burr
was saying when it's special which is
paper tigers one of the best of him in
last 10 years yeah it sticks and stones
a paper tiger back to back it's like
it's a [ __ ] fail I told burr you
maybe want to quit it's so gorgeous like
it was so good so it's so knowing how
good specialist he was saying I forget
what podcast he was on maybe it's his
and he was like yeah you know I got on
Instagram is like you know what I know
it's a good special I'm just gonna get
on there and read a few comes to us and
I get six deep and it's like [ __ ] yeah
dude it's so funny you said that because
I know on Saturday my girlfriend's like
what do you want to do on Saturday I'm
terrible at celebrating myself I don't
worry I'd rather do the work my
girlfriend's like what do you want to on
Saturday your HBO specials coming up you
say move out and get my own place
yeah I was like stop bugging me no I
said I was like I honestly I want to get
dinner in Queens I want to smoke a joint
and I want to watch the Irishman with
you and just hang out what and she was
like she was like let's do that lets
just play Mario Kart
let's just [ __ ] let's just hang out
he's a knight and I'm like you know what
I kind of want to watch the intro
because I want to see the Shh
and then like the actual apol yeah the
second I hit the stage is Irish River
yes sir but it it's it is one of those
things where you
the negative always outweighs the the
positive the way we're wired and it's
it's I can't stand anything I do yeah I
can't stand anything discussed on this
it's no work I had you know what I did
and I recommend this for all comedians
next time you're editing a special they
sent me the audio first and I listened
to the audio they edited it and then I
was kind of like alright this joke
should be a little different and then
when I went into the editing Bay to
watch it I was kind of like I knew how
the set went so I was like alright I
kind of want to see this but dude it's
if Bill burr is feeling that there's no
one that's gonna be safe and calm be
such a long game why why blow yourself
well you just keep doing it yeah keep
writing it's what Picasso said he just
kept painting when he was killing you
should you should be worried if he show
up for shown there's no in the crowd I
thought that was most of my day now at
self-promotion regardless if there's
noble if there's no crowd there then
it's like oh maybe it's really
culturally if you're Irish if you're
yeah yeah you're raised to be you're
raised like any of that [ __ ] is I grew
up in a house my mom was like who the
[ __ ] do you think you are like no one
are you sure that's right god damn right
that's right you have to go hey come see
me I'm amazing well I had such a he he
helped me yeah I do it Rogan were the
ones cuz I I had such I was allergic
yeah to anything I was like I can't do
this I didn't know you know and but you
know you learn by the way translates to
butts in the seats you must do it and
yeah I still don't do it well I still
don't do it well enough because here's
the thing about Brian Brian has more
talent than any comics we know any guys
you listed has more talent than all of
us and as soon as these people get to
know counts he said you're talking
you're talking arenas like that's where
he should be asking me and Whitney were
timeout like everyone knows how good
talent so it's like if you just be a
little better at the self-promotion yeah
I'm gonna sit down that's my next thing
I was thinking about cuz I'm getting
lazy
yeah that's that's the not into it
that's the talent is overrated part
that's your apply practice is it and by
the way same for me I don't [ __ ] I'm
just kind of like I don't know the work
speaks for itself
like no [ __ ] no no
the work because there's there's too
much right now yeah yeah yeah yeah watch
your tongue oh good
what's gonna happen what are you gonna
do use some of that boxing you've been
doing
[Laughter]